payer les patients atteints du coc vite
19 pour qu'il s'isole
c'est la solution originale du
gouvernement de la province de buenos
ars pour tenter de contenir le nombre de
contaminations dans la région un
programme dénommé accompagné offre aux
patients légèrement atteints ou
asymptomatiques une subvention de 500
pesos argentins par jour soit environ 6
euros afin de s'isoler dans un
établissement extrahospitalier la
municipalité de buenos ars a ainsi
ouvert dans le parc des expositions
technopolis une structure qui pourrait
accueillir jusqu'à 2000 patients les
patients qui viennent de manière
générale ont plus de 18 ans et moins de
60 ans c'est l'âge à risque que nous
identifions dans le cadre de la pandémie
ceux qui viennent ici au subi un test de
dépistage positif avec des symptômes
légers ou asymptomatiques qui peuvent se
déplacer pourrait se confiner chez eux
mais leurs conditions de vie ne
permettent pas un confinement sans
mettre les autres en danger
ils sont alors hébergés dans des
dispositifs tels que le parc de santé de
technopolis une initiative qui divise
les habitants de la capitale
c'est une motivation je ne sais pas si
c'est correct de leur offrir de l'argent
mais c'est la seule façon de faire
prendre conscience aux gens de prendre
soin d'eux mêmes et de ne pas contaminer
les autres
je pense que non que c'est mal je ne
donnerai absolument rien
ce que je ferai c'est laisser les gens
travailler avec les protections
adéquates
c'est mon avis cela me semble fou si
vous avez des symptômes
vous devriez y aller car il est de notre
devoir d'y aller pour vous pour votre
famille et pour le reste
si bruno crs et son agglomération
représente 90% des cas de coronavirus
dans le pays
cela n'a pas empêché la municipalité de
commencer ce lundi un des convives mans
progressif une décision avant tout
économique
le fonds monétaire international
anticipe une contraction de l'économie
argentine de près de 10% cette année